con una victoria decide refiriendo un
constitucional a las ocho propuestas de
reforma pasarán inmediatamente a
enmendar a la Constitución ya que
Instagram en vigencia al proclamarse los
resultados oficiales por parte del
Consejo Nacional electoral que cuenta
con diez días para proclamar los
resultados por ley Ecuador contará con
extradición de personas inmersas en
delitos de crimen organizado se creará
el consejo fiscal en la fiscalía pasará
a tener autonomía para evaluar Designar
o ascender Fiscales se modificará la
estructura de integración parlamentaria
de la asamblea nacional reduciendo el
número de asambleístas el proceso de
designación de los miembros del Consejo
de participación ciudadana y control
social perderá su atribución de elegir
autoridades un poco más del 73 pasando
esta atribución al parlamento se creará
un subsistema de progresión hídrica y
servicios ambientales por compensaciones
financieras en total 14 artículos de la
constitución que serán enmendados con
una victoria del sí se traduciría en un
voto de confianza para Guillermo golazo
quien tiene 18 meses gobernando sin el
apoyo de la asamblea nacional con la
peor crisis de seguridad y cifras de
muertes violentas del andino en un
momento que su gobierno maneja poca
aprobación y rodeado por escándalos de
supuesta corrupción en el sector
eléctrico y hermoso podría forzar a la
oposición a plegarse en algunas de sus
reformas clave